Let's say you're miserable and unhappy.
Okay,
here's a cure.
Find what's valuable and let it go.
So we could say,
well,
maybe it's a relationship that you have.
Maybe it's relationship with your
parents,
right,
and the relationship is pathological,
but you're locked into it.
You value it and no wonder because it's
a relationship with your parents and
your suffering terribly because of it.
Well,
what do you do?
Maybe you let it go.
It's a sacrifice and the idea is that,
well,
that'll clear the future for you.
Well,
very frequently when people are
suffering terribly,
not always because sometimes you just
suffer stupidly,
blindly and without recourse,
you know you get cancer and then you
die,
so we have no idea how to deal with
that,
but sometimes the reason that you're
suffering is because you just won't let
go of the thing that's biting you and
you think,
well,
I can't let go of that,
and I've had clients like this.
I can't stop communicating with my
mother who phones me three times a day
everyday of my life and never says
anything that isn't unbelievably
critical and demeaning.
I can't let that go.
I was like,
wow,
that's not such a good idea.
The funny thing too,
often when people let something like
that go,
it goes away,
sorts itself out and then comes back so
they don't even end up losing it,
but unless they're willing to let it go
to sacrifice that they make no headway
whatsoever.
And so one of the rules is if people are
impeding your development,
you sacrifice your relationship with
them,
right?
It's a very,
very rough rule.
So.